thank you so much nate three square is
back to tell us how they're helping our
local seniors keep their kitchen stocked
and their health intact take a look lisa
welcome back
yeah thanks for having me of course i
love telling are spreading the word
about this program
the three square golden groceries
program just kind of introduce us
to it if people haven't didn't see it
the last time oh sure so
it's our program for those that are 60
and better as we like to say and it's
lean proteins whole grains fresh produce
and it's a supplemental grocery program
and we offer delivery and curbside and
lift rides because we know that
transportation can definitely be a
problem
and we're really excited to be
introducing this program
i love it and how does food insecurity
affect our senior population here in
southern nevada i hear
the numbers are pretty big yeah
unfortunately they are
and even the numbers that we have were
pre-coveted and so we know that
everything has gotten much worse
um but we do know that there's a lack of
affordable housing here and so often
times after
you know older adults pay for their
mortgage or their rent for the month
that they are
left with the decision whether they
should pay for their medication or eat
food and we don't want people making
that decision
no that's awful and what separates the
golden groceries program from the other
programs you know that people mostly
know about with you guys
yeah that's a great question and it's
really this program focuses it's a
client choice program so again it's for
those that are 60 and better that's the
only qualification that we have
we don't look at income or health or
immigration status or anything like that
and we just know that um it's a much
needed program
and that it's client choice meaning that
you can pick the items that you want we
want there to be a lot of dignity in
this experience
because you and i get to go to the store
and we get to pick the items that we
want and so people
walk through the aisles and take our
time
yes and we want that same experience um
regardless of where you get your food
from or whether you're able to afford it
or not and so
we really just want to focus on this
higher quality of nutrition that we know
that um seniors need so
and i like that you guys call it a
one-size-fits-all approach or experience
yeah definitely and um and the reason
why we can say that is because there's
so many
different um elements to the program
like i said you can get home delivery
you can go pick up curbside if you want
to get out of your house
we know a lot of seniors right now
aren't wanting to leave their homes and
so
um we can deliver to you or if you want
to leave but don't have the means to we
can come get you in a lift right and we
schedule those in real time there's no
cell phone or smartphone needed
and we'll take you to one of our golden
grocery locations that's awesome and how
can seniors actually access the program
well it's kind of like a one-stop
shopping we just have one phone number
that you have to call so if
you or someone that you know needs help
call 702-765-4030
and one of our caring advocates um can
assist you with all the options that we
have
and determine what is the best program
um with your lead
all right lisa thank you so much again
yeah thank you so much have a great day
you too that number is again right there
on your screen or just visit
threesquare.org
we'll be right back here in las vegas